hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half an hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the political editor of
the scottish son rachel watson and
editor-in-chief of open democracy peter
gagan so let's take a look at what is on
some of those front pages well the eye
reports on the tory leadership race
ahead of the first live tv debate
between the two final contenders
the telegraph leads on rishi sunak's
accusation that liz truss was soft on
china's influence on british
universities while she was education
minister
but the daily mail says liz truss has
herself called mr sunax get tough stance
on china into question
the daily express also goes with the
race to number 10 as liz truss says her
tax breaks will boost britain
and the metro leads on a damning report
by mps set to be released tomorrow which
warns that the nhs and social care
services face their worst workforce
crisis in history
the guardian also quotes that report
which says the challenges facing the
health service could lead to patients
being at risk of harm
the times warns that british holiday
makers face hours of queues at dover and
folkston over the rest of the summer as
a result of tougher border checks
and the daily star says that we can
expect four further heat waves this
summer after the uk saw its hottest ever
day
this week
and the sun has reality tv lauren lauren
googer's request for a post-mortem after
her baby daughter died earlier this
month
just a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out all of the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you sit and watch us well tonight we are
joined by rachel watson and peter gagan
very good evening to you happy sunday
evening to you both um
let's start with the front page
of the eye it seems to be a statement of
the bleeding obvious doesn't it tory
race to be next pm turns toxic it's not
like they're going to be pretending to
be
bosom buddies um
how do you think
they are managing to
differentiate themselves rachel to you
first
yeah i think so you say it's very
obvious that this story debates the
leadership election has become very
bitter and increasingly so over the last
couple of weeks we saw it when penny
morgan was still in the race actually
the papers a couple of papers went for
her there was a lot of briefing against
her
and it seems like it's the shame with
this as well if you look across the
papers tomorrow there's briefings from
either side they're talking about tax
policy
immigration national security just
trying to be
different from one another or push the
other one down on the other one so you
know the stance on china for example is
used a lot in the papers tomorrow we're
pivoting away from tax and the economy
slightly and but i think there will be
this real push between um liz trust and
rishi sanek at the moment but the
problem with that is that actually this
election this leadership race so many
people in the party who have spoken to
senior politicians needed and wanted
this to be about unifying the party
because the last few months partygate
scandal and other issues with the party
really have not set the tories in a good
light in the rest of the uk and they
wanted this to be about the party coming
together but you know you just see this
attacks on each other one of these
people has to be the prime minister and
one of them will have to get in behind
that prime minister
and otherwise it's not going to be a
good look for them going into the next
general election so it's getting
increasingly better with six weeks left
to go you know how far is this going to
go that's interesting and peter in terms
of the tory members because that's
really who they need to be winning over
now uh
where are the most significant
divergences which give give them
something to hang their hat on in terms
of who they pick
is it the economy well it's quite
it's quite remarkable it's what you can
see from the front pages tonight and
then you've seen it really you know i
saw the star i think it said i'm gonna
have four more heat waves this summer
we're gonna definitely have six more
weeks of this kind of you know kind of
sniping attacks from soon i can trust
but what's quite the most striking i
think about this is that they seem so
detached from reality you know we're
talking about front pages headlines
about nhs chronic problems inflation
running ten percent and you have what
looked like really really niche
interests around the role of china and
british universities um tax cuts etc and
there clearly are yes this is how the
election now works where we our next
premise is going to be chosen by a very
very small selector of 170 000 tory
members and what we're seeing and what's
almost most interesting about the papers
today is is kind of where they're coming
from where you've got both the mail and
the express who clearly are very much in
team liz trust and are really putting
the boost into rishi sunak and i think
that's gonna be probably the tone of the
next few weeks is that the right wing
papers have clearly come out pretty
strongly for liz trust so while they
continue this they're going to go very
hard against uh sunak and meanwhile i
would expect the rest of the newspapers
are going to cover what are the really
big issues in this country at the moment
which are you know are pretty massive in
the climate to
the cost of living to the state of the
nhs and we're showing the front page of
the daily mail there rachel in china
um
i i guess the general public have a view
on whether that matters to them and i'd
imagine that it doesn't matter very much
at the moment compared to travel
disruption
nhs backlogs does it matter to tory
members
yes peter said there's so many issues
that are impacting people's lives just
now whether that's fossil living nhs
that people really want to hear about
but also as they said this is a very
small electorate that the that liz trust
and rishi surak are talking to and they
want to hear issues that they you know
we're going to be tough on they want to
hear that that the conservatives are
going to be tough on china they want to
hear these policies around immigration
and tax this is what they
believe that the membership want to hear
and i think you know it was an interest
it's an interesting move to pivot so
quickly we spoke about you know we
didn't really get into
when we first had the leadership race
the beginning of it kind of lacked
policy nobody was really talking about
what they wanted to do other than tax
cuts um but now we've kind of you know
wishy senick was very comfortable
talking about that those and i think liz
trust and her campaign have seen
the china comments that he's made today
about you know getting off on china and
the investment in uk universities from
the chinese state you know she's seen
this as something or people in her
campaign have come back at and said
you know
really like what are you talking about
and i think that they have seen this as
something that he might not be
as well kind of bred on as they hope
that liz trust's foreign secretary will
be
um but this is obviously something that
they believe that they are talking to a
very small electorate and that they will
like you know liz trust is very much
seen as the right-wing candidate in this
election
and rishi sunak is you know the the more
centrist he's very careful with tax cuts
for example but he's going to have to
kind of try and get himself back into
this race between poland figures where
liz tross is ahead of him and there will
be that you know push for wishes to
actually kind of lean more to the right
now
yeah and given that we're saying that
it's a niche
issue perhaps we won't go to the daily
telegraph which is also talking about
any even more niche aspect of this
talking as you were saying there about
liz truss's
involvement in
china's influence in the university
should we move on to something that i
think probably more people
could get excited about and not in a
good way and that's on the front of the
guardian
peter talking about this
colossal staffing crisis in the nhs
yes and there's been quite a bit of
trailing of this over the last few days
as well there's some stories in the
sunday times this morning about the
scale of the staffing crisis in the nhs
and i think like for a lot of people who
are engaging with the health service
these are the kind of issues that they
are going to be seeing and what we're
you know there's a big new briefiness
coming out from the um health committee
at the house commons which is chaired by
jeremy hunt but it's a cross-party
committee it's seen as very influential
it's seen broadly as not necessarily
being pro or anti-government so warning
like this coming from that committee is
seen as very significant and you know
it's not really a surprise there's been
many a decade plus of austerity a series
of cuts to the health service and what
we are seeing is a lot of people in
their everyday lives and interaction
with the health service are seeing the
the reality of the staff in crisis and
you would expect unfortunately this is
the summer we do have coldwood we have a
kind of you know we do have very hard
devils of coal but again some of that
seems to be going through into health
service but we are not at the winter yet
so you know in many ways a bit like the
cost of living pertains to uh heating
people's homes we're on the kind of easy
side of it compared to what we're seeing
likely coming down the track and if this
warning from coming from mp's anything
to go by the next few months will be
very very very hard for the nhs
um rachel whoever gets the health brief
in the new prime minister's
cabinet's going to have an almighty
great job on their hands aren't they
yeah this is absolutely one of the areas
that has to be top priority for a new
prime minister and they will need to put
health secretary in that can deal with
this you know it'll have to be someone
that is ready to take this on as peter
said you know this is summer the summer
is usually that quieter stretch the nhs
and we get into winter and all those
other viruses and illnesses that come on
top of um the usual pressures that the
nhs face but we don't only have that we
have ovid and we also have these huge
back blocks and delays from the padlock
as well when things were put off you
know there's still huge demand on the
nhs and it's only going to get worse
throughout the winter and i think
looking at some of the figures and there
was only figures for england in this
report but you know 12 000 hospital
doctors and 50 000 nurse and midwifery
vacancies in the nhs in england is
absolutely well those are incredible
figures um when you think about it and
this isn't you know the pressure on the
nhs is not just the pandemic either you
know there was already pressures on the
nhs this has been a long time coming and
it's obviously been made worse by the
pad limit but for any health secretary
this is something they really have to
get on top of as quickly as possible